hello your highness what can I do for
you well let me see if I can count that
let's say you have one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten monkeys
yup you're right you only have ten well
well maybe our friends who are listening
or watching could could figure that on
our own how many monkeys would the Queen
need now that she has ten monkeys how
many more would she need in order to
have 18 so I'm assuming our friends have
had a go at it so let's think about this
together so let's see if we let's think
about how many more monkeys to get to 18
so if we have one more monkey that gets
us to one more monkeys going to get us
to 11 right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 then
another one is going to get us to
another one is going to get us to 12 and
then another one is going to get us to
13 13 let's keep doing that 14 14 almost
there
15 let me write that down 15 and then 16
16 and then 17 17 and then 18 whoops and
then 18 monkeys so that's our goal we
wanted to get to 18 so how many did we
let's think about this we had 10 before
so all of these up here all of these up
here these are 10 monkeys let's see so
that is 10 monkeys right over there and
then we added one two three four five
six seven eight
so we added eight eight monkeys to those
two those 10 to those 10 so we added
eight in order to get to 18 in order to
get to 18 or another way to think about
it
18 18 is the same thing is equal to 10
plus 8 10 Plus 8 thank you so much
having sufficient ease at my party no
thank you it's always a pleasure to help
you Queen and actually I think I'm
noticing an interesting pattern right
over here notice 18 is 10 plus 8 I
wonder if that's a pattern in general so
if I had if I had say well let's say we
had 10 let's say we had the number 10
the number 10 by itself that's the same
thing as 10 10 this is 1 10 right over
here plus zero ones so it's 1 10 plus 0
ones the number 11 the number 11 is
equal to 110 so this one right over here
represents a 10 and then this one
represents one more 1 so plus 1 and I
and just like that we could keep going
and I encourage our friend listening to
try this on our own look at all of the
numbers keep counting from 1011 all the
way up to you could count all the way up
to 19 and see this pattern notice 18
this one right over
year it represents this one right over
here represents one ten and then this
eight over here represents eight so when
we say how do we if we start with ten
how much do we have to add to get to 18
well the ten is this one here so we need
eight more ones 10 plus 8 is 18 oh thank
you so much so not only were the pop
monkeys at my party I now know a little
bit more about mathematics oh you're
very welcome Queen